the following is a conversation with
Whitney Cummings she's a stand-up
comedian actor producer writer director
and recently finally the host of her
very own podcast called good for you
her most recent Netflix special called
can I touch it features in part of robot
she affectionately named bear claw but
it's designed to be visually a replica
Whitney it's exciting for me to see one
of my favorite comedians explore the
social aspects of robotics and AI in our
society she also has some fascinating
ideas about human behavior psychology
and neurology some of which she explores
in her book called um fine and other
lies there's truly a pleasure to meet
Whitney and have this conversation with
her and he went to continue it through
texts afterwards every once in a while
late at night I'll be programming over a
cup of coffee and we'll get a text from
Whitney saying something hilarious or
weirder yet sending a video Bryan Callen
saying something hilarious that's what I
know the universe has a sense of humor
and he gifted me with one hell of an
amazing journey then I put the phone
down and go back to programming with a
stupid joyful smile on my face if you
enjoy this conversation listen to it in
these podcasts good for you and follow
her on Twitter and Instagram this is the
artificial intelligence podcast if you
enjoy subscribe on YouTube good five
stars on Apple podcasts support on
patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter Alex Friedman spelled Fri D M
a.m.
this shows presented by cash app the
number one finance I have in the App
Store they regularly support Whitney's
good-for-you podcast as well I
personally used cash app to some money
to friends but you can also use it to
buy sell and deposit Bitcoin in just
seconds cash app also has a new
investing feature you can buy a fraction
of stock say $1 worth no matter what the
stock price is brokerage services are
provided by kept investing subsidiary of
square and member at CIBC I'm excited to
be working with cash app to support one
of my favorite organizations called
first best known for their first
robotics and Lego competitions they
educate and inspire hundreds of
thousands of stew
and in over 110 countries and have a
perfect rating and Charity Navigator
which means the donated money is used to
maximum effectiveness when you get cash
app from the App Store or Google Play
and use code Lex podcast you get $10 and
cash app will also donate $10 to 1st
which again is an organization that
personally seen inspired girls and boys
to dream of engineering a better world
this podcast is supported by zip
recruiter hiring great people is hard
and to me is the most important element
of a successful mission driven team I've
been fortunate to be a part of and to
lead several great engineering teams the
hiring I've done in the past was mostly
the tools that we built ourselves but
reinventing the wheel was painful so zip
recruiters a tool that's already
available for you it seeks to make
hiring simple fast and smart
for example codable co-founder Gretchen
Abner used the recruiter to find a new
game artist to join her education tech
company by using zip recruiter screening
questions to filter candidates
Gretchen found it easier to focus on the
best candidates and finally hiring the
perfect person for the role in less than
two weeks from start to finish
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
cy zip recruiters effective for
businesses of all sizes by signing up as
I did for free at zip recruiter comm
slash Lex pod that's zip recruiter calm
slash Lex pod and now here's my
conversation with Whitney Cummings
I have trouble making eye contact as you
can tell me too do you know that I had
to work on making eye contact because I
used to look here do you see that yeah
do you want me to do that
I'll do this well chief to camera but I
used to do this and finally people like
I'd be on dates and guys would be like
are you looking at my hair like they get
it would make people really insecure
because I didn't really get a lot of eye
contact as a kid it's it's one two three
years did you not get a lot of my
contact as a kid I don't know I haven't
done the soul-searching right so I but
there's definitely some psychological is
she makes me uncomfortable yeah for some
reason want to connect eyes I start to
think I assume that you're judging me oh
why am we all are all right the POC has
to be me and you both do you think
robots of the future ones with human
level intelligence will be female male
genderless or another gender who have
not yet created as a society you're the
expert at this well I'm gonna ask you
the answer I'm gonna ask you questions
that maybe nobody knows the answer to or
alright and then I just want you to
hypothesize as a as a imaginative author
director comedian can we just be very
clear that you know a ton about this and
I know nothing about this but I have
thought a lot about yes what I think
robots can fix in our society and I mean
I'm a comedian it's my job to study
human nature to make jokes about human
nature and to sometimes play devil's
advocate and I just see such a
tremendous negativity around robots or
at least the idea of robots that it was
like oh I'm just gonna take the opposite
side for fun for jokes and then I was
like oh no I really agree and this
devil's advocate argument so I please
correct me when I'm wrong about this
stuff so so first of all there's there's
no right and wrong because we're all I
think most of the people working on
robotics are really not actually even
thinking about some of the big picture
things that you've been exploring in
fact uh your robot what's-her-name by
the
we'll go on bear claw
what's the genesis of that name by the
way would bear claw was I god I don't
even remember the joke cuz i black out
after I shoot specials but I was writing
something about like the pet names that
men call women like cupcake sweetie
honey you know like we're always named
after desserts or something and I was
just writing a joke about um if you want
to call us a dessert at least pick like
a cool dessert you know like bear claw
like something cool so I ended up
calling her bad luck so do you think the
future robots of greater and greater
intelligence will like to make them
female male would we like to assign them
gender or would we'd like to move away
from gender and say something more
ambiguous I think it depends on their
purpose you know I feel like if it's a
sex robot it people prefer certain
genders you know and I also you know
when I went down and explored the robot
Factory I was asking about the type of
people that bought sex robots and I was
very surprised at the answer because of
course the stereotype was it's gonna be
a bunch of perverts it ended up being a
lot of people that were handicapped a
lot of people with erectile dysfunction
and a lot of people that were exploring
their sexuality a lot of people that
were thought they were gay but weren't
sure but didn't want to take the risk of
trying on someone that could reject them
and being embarrassed or they were
closeted or in a city where maybe that's
you know taboo and stigmatized you know
so I think that a gendered sex robot
that would serve an important purpose
for someone trying to explore their
sexuality am i into man let me try on
this thing first alien to women let me
try on this thing first so I think
gendered robots would be important for
that I think genderless robots in terms
of emotional support robots babysitters
I'm fine for a genderless babysitter
with my husband in the house you know
there are places that I think that
genderless makes a lot of sense but
obviously not in the sex area what do
you mean with your husband in the house
what does that have to do with the
gender of the robot but I mean I don't
have a husband but hypothetically
speaking I think every woman's worst
nightmare is like the hot babysitter
you know so I think that there is a
common place I think for genderless you
know teachers doctors all that kind of
it would be very awkward if the first
robotic doctor was a guy or the first
robotic nurse is a woman you know it's
sort of that stuff is still loaded I
think that genderless could just take
the unnecessary drama out of it and
possibility to sexualize them or be
triggered by any of that stuff so
there's two components to this it's a
bear claw so one is the voice and the
talking so on and then there's the
visual appearance so on the topic of
gender and generalists in your
experience what has been the value of
the physical appearance so what has it
added much to the depth of the
interaction I mean mines
kind of an extenuating circumstance
because she is supposed to look exactly
like me I mean I spent six months
getting my face molded and having you
know the idea was I was exploring the
concept of Ken robots replace us because
that's the big fear but also the big
dream in a lot of ways and I wanted to
dig into that area because you know for
a lot of people it's like they're gonna
take our jobs they're gonna replace us
legitimate fear but then a lot of women
I know are like I would love for a robot
to replace me every now and then so it
can go to baby showers for me and it can
pick up my kids at school and it can
cook dinner and whatever so I just think
that was an interesting place to explore
so her looking like me was a big part of
it now her looking like me just adds an
unnecessary level of insecurity cuz I
got our year ago and she already looks
younger than me so weird problem yeah
but I think that her looking human was
the idea and I think that where we are
now please correct me if I'm wrong over
human robot resembling an actual human
you know is going to feel more realistic
than some generic face what you're
saying that that robots that have some
familiarity like looks similar to
somebody that you actually know you be
able to form a deeper connection with
that was the question that's an open
question I don't I don't
no it's an interesting or the opposite
if then you know me and you're like why
I know this isn't real because you're
right here maybe it does the opposite we
have a very keen eye for human faces and
they're able to detect strangeness
especially that one has to do with
people we've whose faces we've seen a
lot of them so I tend to be a bigger fan
of moving away completely from faces
recognizable faces no just human faces
at all in general because I think that's
where things get dicey and one thing I
will say is I think my robot is more
realistic than other robots not
necessarily because you have seen me and
then you see heard you go oh they're so
similar but also because human faces are
flawed and asymmetrical and sometimes we
forget when we're making things that
supposed to look human we make them too
symmetrical and that's what makes them
stop looking human so because they mold
in my symmetrical face she just even if
someone didn't know who I was I think
she'd look more realistic than most
generic ones that didn't have some kind
of flaws got it you know cuz they start
looking creepy when they're too
symmetrical because human beings aren't
ya know the flaws is what it means to be
human so visually as well but I'm just a
fan of the idea of letting humans use a
little bit more imagination so just
hearing the voice is enough for us
humans to then start imagining the
visual appearance that goes along with
that voice and you don't necessarily
need to work too hard on creating the
actual visual appearance mm-hmm so
there's some value to that when you step
into the stereo of actually building a
robot that looks like bear claws such a
long road of facial expressions of sort
of making everything smiling winking yep
rolling their eyes all that kind of
stuff it gets really really tricky it
gets tricky and I think I'm again I'm a
comedian like I'm obsessed with what
makes us human and our human nature and
the nasty side of human nature tends to
be where I've you know ended up
exploring over and over again and I was
just mostly fascinated by people's
reactions so it's my job to get the
biggest reaction from a group of
strangers the loudest possible reaction
and I just had this instinct just when I
started building her and people go
oh and screechin people scream in there
I mean I bring around on stage and
people would scream and I just to me
that was the next level of entertainment
getting a laugh I've done that I know
how to do that I think comedians were
always trying to figure out what the
next level is and comedies evolving so
much and you know Jordan Peele had just
done you know these genius comedy horror
movies which feel like the next level of
comedy to me and this sort of funny
horror of a robot was fascinating to me
but I think the thing that I got the
most obsessed with was people being
freaked out and scared of her and I
started digging around with pathogen
avoidance and the idea that we've
essentially evolved to be repelled by
anything that looks human but is off a
little bit anything that could be sick
or diseased or dead essentially as our
reptilian brains way to get us to not
Procrit try to have sex with it
basically you know so I got really
fascinated by how freaked out and scared
I mean I would see grown men get upset
you get something away from me like
angry and it was like you know that what
this is you you know but the sort of
like you know amygdala getting activated
by something that to me is just a fun
toy said a lot about our history as a
species and what got us into trouble
thousands of years ago so it's that it's
the deep down stuff that's in our
genetics but also is it just are people
freaked out by the fact that there's a
robot so it's not just the appearance
but there's an artificial human anything
people I think and I'm just always also
fascinated by the blind spots humans
have so the idea that you're afraid of
that I mean how many robots have killed
people how many humans have died at the
hands of other humans yeah many more
hundreds of millions yet we're scared of
that and we'll go to the grocery store
and be around a bunch of humans who
statistically the chances are much
higher that you're gonna get killed by
humans so I'm just fascinated by without
judgement how irrational we are is the
worry is the exponential so it's you
know you could say the same thing about
nuclear weapons before we dropped on
Hiroshima
Masaki so the worry that people have is
the exponential growth so so it's like
oh it's fun and games right now but you
know overnight especially if a robot
provides value to society we'll put one
in every home and then all of a sudden
lose track of the actual large-scale
impact it has in society and then all
sudden gain greater and greater control
to where we'll all be you know affect
our political system and then affect our
decision did not just already happen
which ones Oh Russia hacking no offense
but hasn't already happened I mean that
was like an algorithm of negative things
being clicked on more we'd like to tell
stories and like to demonize certain
people I think nobody understands our
current political system or discourse on
Twitter the Twitter mobs nobody has a
sense not Twitter not Facebook the
people running it nobody understands the
impact for these algorithms they're
trying their best yeah despite what
people think they're not like a bunch of
lefties trying to make sure that Hillary
Clinton gets elected it's more that it's
an incredibly complex system that we
don't and that's the worry it's so
complex and moves so fast that nobody
will be able to stop it once it happens
and let me ask the question this is a
very savage question yeah which is is
this just the next stage of evolution as
humans and people will die yes I mean
that's always happens you know is this
is just taking emotion out of it is this
basically the next stage of survival of
the fittest yeah you have to think of
organisms you know what is it mean to be
a living organism like it's a smartphone
part of your living organism or where
we're in relationships with our phones
yeah but it's sex through them with them
what's the difference between with them
and through them but it also expands
your cognitive abilities expands your
memory knowledge and so on so you're a
much smarter person because you have a
smart phone in your hand but if what as
soon as it's out of my hands we've got
big problems because we become sort of
so morphed with them
with an assembly otic relationship and
that's what the er mosque when you're a
link is working on trying to increase
the bandwidth communication between
computers and your brain and so further
and further expand our ability as human
beings to sort of leverage machines and
maybe that's the future the evolution
next evolutionary step it could be also
that yes we'll give birth just like we
give birth to human children right now
to give birth day I in other places I
think it's a really interesting
possibility I'm gonna play devil's
advocate I just think that the fear of
robots is wildly classist because I mean
Facebook like it's easy for us to say
they're taking their data okay a lot of
people that get employment off of
Facebook they are able to get income off
of Facebook they don't care if you take
their phone numbers and their emails and
their data as long as it's free they
don't want to have to pay five dollars a
month or Facebook Facebook is a wildly
Democratic thing forget about the
election and all that kind of stuff you
know a lot of you know technology making
people's lives easier it I find that
most elite people are more scared than
lower-income people so and women for the
most part so the idea of something
that's stronger than us and that might
eventually kill us like women are used
to that like that's not I see a lot of
like really wit rich men being like the
robots are gonna kill us we're like
what's another thing that's gonna kill
us you know I tend to see like oh
something can walk me to my car at night
like something can help me cook dinner
or something you know for you know
people in underprivileged countries who
can't afford eye surgery like you know
robot can we send a robot to
under-privileged you know places to do
surgery where they can't I work with
this organization cooperation smile
where they do cleft palate surgeries and
there's a lot of places that can't do a
very simple surgery because they can't
afford doctors and medical care and such
so I just see and this can be completely
naive and should be completely wrong but
I feel like we're a lot of people are
going like the robots are gonna destroy
us humans we're destroying ourselves
we're self-destructing robots to me are
the only hope to clean up all the messes
that we've created even when we go try
to clean up pollution in the ocean we
make it worse because of the oil that
the tankers
it's like to me robots are the only
solution you know firefighters are
heroes but they're limited and how many
times they can run into a fire you know
so there's just something interesting to
me I'm not hearing a lot of like lower
income more vulnerable populations
talking about robots maybe you can speak
that a little bit more there's an idea I
think you've expressed that I've heard
actually a few female writers and
roboticist I've talked to express this
idea that exactly you just said which is
it just seems that being being afraid of
existential threats of artificial
intelligence is is a male issue yeah it
and I wonder what that is
if it because because men have in
certain positions like you said it's
also classist issue they haven't been
humbled by life and so you're always
look for the biggest problems to take on
around you it's a champagne problem to
be afraid of robots most people like
don't have health insurance they're
afraid they're not gonna be able to feed
their kids they can't afford a tutor for
their kids like I mean I just think of
you know the way I grew up and I had a
mother who you know work two jobs had
kids we couldn't afford an SAT tutor you
know like we could idea of a robot
coming and being able to tutor your kids
being able to provide childcare for your
kids you know being able to come in with
cameras for eyes and make sure you know
surveillance you know I'm very Pro
surveillance because you know I've had
security problems and I've been you know
we're generally in a little more danger
than you guys are so I think that robots
are a little less scary to us because we
could see them maybe as like free
assistance help and protection and then
there's sort of another element for me
personally which is maybe more of a
female problem I don't know I'm just
gonna make a generalization I'm happy to
be wrong but you know the emotional sort
of component of robots and what they can
provide in terms of you know there I
think there's a lot of people that
aren't don't have microphones that I
just recently kind of stumbled upon in
doing all my research on the sex robots
for my stand-up special which there's a
lot of very shy people that aren't good
at day
there's a lot of people who are scared
of human beings who you know have
personality disorders or grow up in
alcoholic homes or struggle with
addiction or whatever it is where a
robot can solve an emotional problem
and so we're largely having this
conversation about like rich guys that
are emotionally healthy and how scared
of robots are we're forgetting about
like a huge part of the population who
maybe isn't as charming and effervescent
and salt mint as you know people like
you and Allah mask who these robots
could solve very real problems in their
life emotional or financial that's a in
general really interesting idea that
most people in the world don't have a
voice it's you've talked about it sort
of even the people on Twitter who are
driving the conversation you said
comments people who leave comments
represent a very tiny percent of the
population and they're the ones they you
know we tend to think they speak for the
population but it's very possible on
many topics they don't at all and look I
and I'm sure there's got to be some kind
of legal you know sort of structure in
place for when the robots happen you
know way more about this than I do but
you know for me to just go the robots
are bad that's a wild generalization
that I feel like is really inhumane in
some way you know just after the
research I've done like you're gonna
tell me that a man whose wife died
suddenly and he feels guilty moving on
with a human woman or can't get over the
grief he can't have a sex robot in his
own house well why not who cares why do
you care well there's a interesting
aspect of human nature so you know we
tend to as a as a civilization to create
a group that's the other in all kinds of
ways right and so you work with animals
too you've you're especially sensitive
to the suffering of animals let me kind
of ask what's your do you think will
abuse robots in the future do you think
some of the darker aspects of human
nature will come out I think some people
will but if we design them properly to
people that do it we can put it on a
record and they can we put we can put
them in jail we can find sociopaths more
easily you
like why is that why is that a
sociopathic thing to harm a robot I
think look I don't know is enough enough
about the consciousness and stuff as you
do it I guess it would have to be when
they're conscious but it is you know the
part of the brain that is you know
responsible for compassion the frontal
lobe or whatever like people that abuse
animals also abuse humans and commit
other kinds of crimes like that's it's
all the same part of the brain no one
abuses animals and then it's like
awesome to women and children and
awesome to under-privileged you know
minorities like it's all so you know
we've been working really hard to put a
database together of all the people that
have abused animals so when they commit
another crime you go okay this is you
know it's all the same stuff and I think
people probably think I'm nuts for the a
lot of the animal work I do but because
when animal abuse is president another
crime is always present but the animal
abuse is the most socially acceptable
you can kick a dog and there's nothing
people can do but then what they're
doing behind closed doors you can't see
so there's always something else going
on which is why I never feel compassion
about it but I do think we'll start
seeing the same thing with robots the
person that kicks them I felt compassion
when the kicking the dog robot really
pissed me off
I know that they're just trying to get
the stability right and all that but I
do think there will come a time where
that will be a great way to be able to
figure out if somebody is has like you
know antisocial behaviors you kind of
mentioned surveillance mm-hmm it's also
a really interesting idea of yours he
just said you know a lot of people
should be really uncomfortable with
surveillance yeah and you just said that
you know what for me you know there's
positives for surveillance
I think people behave better when they
know they're being watched and I know
this is a very unpopular opinion I'm
talking about on stage right now I we
behave better when we know we're being
watched you and I had a very different
conversation before we were recording if
we behave different you said I'll be on
your best behavior and I'm trying to
sound eloquent and I'm trying to not
hurt anyone's feelings and I'm gonna
have a camera right there I'm behaving
totally different then we we first
started talking you know when you know
there's a camera you behave differently
I mean there's cameras all over LA at
stoplights
so that people don't run stoplights but
there's not even film in it they don't
even use them anymore but it works it
works right in and I'm you know working
on this thing and stamp out surveillance
it's like that's why we invented Santa
Claus you know it's the Santa Claus is
the first surveillance basically all we
have to say to kids is he's making a
list and he's watching you and that
behaved better I was brilliant you know
so I do I do think that there are
benefits to surveillance you know I
think we all do sketchy things in
private and we all have watched weird
porn or googled weird things and we
don't we don't want people to know about
it the our secret lives so I do think
that obviously there's we should be able
to have a modicum of privacy but I tend
to think the people that are the most
negative about surveillance of the most
high well you should do your thing
you're doing bits on it now well I'm
just talking in general about you know
privacy and surveillance and how
paranoid were kind of becoming and how
you know I mean it's it's just wild to
me that people are like our emails are
gonna leak and they're taking our phone
numbers like there there used to be a
book full of phone numbers and addresses
yeah that word they just throw it at
your door and we all had a book of
everyone's numbers you know is a very
new thing and you know I know our migdal
is designed to compound sort of threats
and you know there's stories about and I
think we all just glom on and a very you
know tribe away yeah they're taking our
data like we don't even know that means
we're like well yeah they they you know
so I just think that someone's like okay
well so what they're gonna sell your
data who cares why do you care first of
all that bit will kill in China so and I
said I said only a little bit joking
because a lot of people in China
including the citizens despite what
people in the West think of as abuse I
actually in supported the idea of
surveillance mmm-hmm sort of they're not
in support of the abuse of surveillance
but they're they like I mean the idea of
surveillance is kind of like the idea of
government it like you said we behave
differently in a way it's um
like why we like sports there's rules
and within the constraints of the rules
this is a more stable society and they
make good arguments about success being
able to build successful companies being
able to build successful social lives
around a fabric that's more stable when
you have a surveillance
it keeps the criminals away keeps
abusive animals whatever the values of
the society with surveillance you can
enforce those values butter and here's
what I will say there's a lot of
unethical things happening with
surveillance like I feel the need to
really make that very clear I mean the
fact that Google is like collecting if
people's hands start moving on the mouse
to find out if they're getting
Parkinson's and then their insurance
goes up like that is completely
unethical and wrong and I think stuff
like that we have to really be careful
around so the idea of using our data to
raise our insurance rates or you know I
heard that they're looking they can sort
of predict if you're gonna have
depression based on your selfies by
detecting micro muscles in your face
that you know all that kind of stuff
that is a nightmare not okay but I think
you know we have to delineate what's a
real threat and what's getting spam in
your email box that's that's not what
you spend your time and energy on focus
on the fact that every time you buy
cigarettes your insurance is not without
you knowing about it
on the topic of animals - can we just
linger a little bit like what do you
think what does it say about our society
of the society white abuse of animals
that we see in general sort of factory
farming is just in general just the way
we treat animals of different categories
like what what do you think of that what
is a better world look like what's what
should people think about it in general
I think um I think the most interesting
thing I can probably say around this
that the least emotional cuz I'm
actually a very non emotional animal
person because it's I think everyone's
an animal person it's just a matter of
its if it's yours or if you've you know
been conditioned to go numb you know I
think it's really a testament to what as
a species we are able to be in denial
about mass denial and mass delusion and
how we're able to do human eyes and do
base groups
you know world war two in a way in order
to conform and find protection and the
conforming so we are also a species who
used to go to Coliseum's and watch
elephants and tigers fight to the death
we used to watch human beings be pulled
apart in the cut there wasn't that long
ago
we're also species who had slaves and it
was socially acceptable by a lot of
people people didn't see anything wrong
with it so we're a species that is able
to go numb and that is able to
dehumanize very quickly and make it the
norm child labor wasn't that long ago
the idea that now we look back and go oh
yeah kids
we're losing fingers and factories
making shoes like someone had to come in
and make that you know so I think it
just that's a lot about the fact that
you know we are animals and we are
self-serving and one of the most
successful the most successful species
because we are able to debase and
degrade and essentially exploit anything
that benefits us I think the pendulum is
gonna swing as being lately like I think
we're wrong now kind of like I think
we're on the verge of collapse because
we are dopamine receptors like we are
just I think we're all kind of addicts
when it comes to this stuff like we
don't know when to stop it's always the
buffet like we're the thing that used to
keep us alive which is killing animals
and eating them now killing animals and
eating them is what's killing us in a
way so it's like we just can't we don't
know when to call it and we don't
moderation it's not really something
that humans have evolved to have yet so
I think it's really just a flaw in our
wiring do you think we'll look back at
this time as our society is being deeply
unethical yeah yeah I think we'll be
embarrassed which are the worst parts
right now going on is it well I think no
in terms of anything
what's the unethical thing if we it's
very hard to take a step out of it but
you just said we used to watch you know
there's been a lot of cruelty throughout
history
what's the cruelty going on now
I think it's gonna be I mean pigs are
one of the most emotional intelligent
animals and they have the intelligence
of like a three-year-old and I think
we'll look back and be really good
there's 30 they use tools I mean they're
I think we have this narrative that
they're pigs and they're pigs and
they're they're disgusting and they're
dirty and their bacon is so I think that
we'll look back one day and be really
embarrassed about that is this for just
uh what's it called the factory farming
so basically mess because we don't see
it if you saw I mean we do have I mean
this is probably an evolutionary
advantage we do have the ability to
completely pretend something's not
something that is so horrific that it
overwhelms us and we're able to
essentially deny that it's happening I
think if people were to see what goes on
in factory farming and also we're really
to take in how bad it is for us you know
we're hurting ourselves first and
foremost with what what we eat but
that's also a very elitist argument you
know it's a luxury to be able to
complain about meat it's a luxury to be
able to not eat meat you know there's
very few people because of you know how
the corporations have set up meat being
cheap you know it's two dollars to buy a
Big Mac it's ten dollars to buy a
healthy meal you know that's I think a
lot of people don't have the luxury to
even think that way
but I do think that animals in captivity
I think we're gonna look back and be
pretty grossed out about mammals in
captivity whales dolphins I mean that's
already starting to dismantle circuses
we're gonna be pretty embarrassed about
but I think it's really more testament
to you know there's just such a ability
to go like that thing is different than
me and we're better it's the ego I mean
it's just we have the species with the
biggest ego ultimately well that's what
I think that that's my hope for robots
is they'll you mentioned consciousness
before nobody knows what consciousness
is but I'm hoping
robots will help us empathize and
understand that that there's other
creatures out besides ourselves that can
suffer that can they can experience the
world and that we can torture by our
actions and robots can explicitly teach
us that I think better than animals can
I have never seen such compassion from a
lot of people in my life toward any
human animal child as I have a lot of
people in the way they interact with the
robot because I should theirs I think
there's something of AI I mean I was on
the robot owners chat boards for a good
eight months and the main emotional
benefit is she's never gonna cheat on
you
she's never gonna hurt you she's never
gonna lie to you she doesn't judge you
you know I think that robots help people
and this is part of the work I do with
animals like I do I find therapy and
trained dogs and stuff because there is
this safe space to be authentic you're
with this being that doesn't care what
you do for a living doesn't care how
much money you have doesn't care who
you're dating doesn't care what you look
like doesn't care if you have cellulite
whatever you feel safe to be able to
truly you know be present without being
defensive and worrying about eye contact
and being triggered by you no need to be
perfect and fear of judgment and all
that and robots really can't judge you
yet but they can't judge you and I think
it really puts people at they're at ease
and at their most authentic do you think
you can have a deep connection with the
robot that's not judging or do you think
you can really have a relationship with
a robot or a human being that's a safe
space or as a tension mystery danger
necessary for a deep connection I'm
gonna speak for myself and say that I
grew up and alcohol Combe I identify as
a codependent talked about this stuff
before but for me it's very hard to be
in relationship with a human being
without feeling like I need to perform
in some way or deliver in some way and I
don't know if that's just the people
I've been in a relationship with or or
me or my brokenness but I do think this
is kind of sound really negative and
pessimistic but I do think a lot of our
relationships are projection and a lot
of our relationships are performance
and I don't think I really understood
that until I worked with horses
and most mutations human is nonverbal
right I can say like I love you but that
you're not you don't think I love you
right where's is with animals it's very
direct it's all physical it's all energy
I feel like that with robots too it
feels very what how I say something
doesn't matter
my inflection doesn't really matter and
you thinking that my tone is
disrespectful like you're not filtering
it through all of the bad relationships
you've been in you're not filtering it
through the way your mom talked to you
you're not getting triggered you know I
find that for the most part people don't
always receive things the way that you
intend them to or the way intended and
that makes relationships really murky so
the relationships with animals and
relationship with the robots as they are
now you kind of implied that that's more
healthy I think can you have a healthy
relationship with other humans or not
healthy and don't like that word but it
shouldn't it be you've talked about
codependency maybe you can talk about
what is called dependency but is that is
the the challenges of that the
complexity of that necessary for passion
for for love between compassion I
thought this would be a safe speech I
got trolled by rogen powers on this I I
am NOT anti passion I think that I've
just maybe been around long enough to
know that sometimes it's ephemeral and
that passion is a mixture of a lot of
different things adrenaline which turns
into dopamine quarters it's a lot of
neuro chemicals it's a lot of projection
it's a lot of what we've seen in movies
it's a lot of you know it's it's I
identify as an addict so for me
sometimes passion is like oh this could
be bad and I think we've been so
conditioned to believe that passion
means like your soul mates and I mean
how many times have you had a passionate
connection with someone and then it was
a total train wreck passionate the train
wreck comedy track exactly a lot of
yawning I mean what's a trainwreck
what's uh wise obsession she described
this codependency and sort of the idea
of attachment / attachment to people who
don't deserve that kind of attachment as
somehow a bad thing and I think our
society says it's a bad thing it
probably is a bad thing like a like a
delicious burgers a bad thing I don't
know but right oh that's a good point I
think that your your pointing out
something really fascinating which is
like passion if you go into it knowing
this is like pizza or it's gonna be
delicious for two hours and then I don't
have to have it again for three if you
can have a choice in the passion i
define passion is something that is
relatively unmanageable and something
you can't control
or stop and start with your own volition
so maybe we're operating under different
definitions if passion is something that
like you know ruins your real marriages
and screws up your professional life and
becomes this thing that you're not in
control of and becomes addictive I think
that's the difference is is it a choice
or is it not a choice and if it is a
choice then passion is great but if it's
something that like consumes you and
makes you start making bad decisions and
clouds your frontal lobe and it's just
all about dopamine and not really about
the person and more about the
neurochemical we call it sort of the
drug the internal drug cabinet if it's
all just you're on drugs that's
different you know because sometimes
you're just on drugs okay so there's a
philosophical questions here so would
you rather it's interesting for a
comedian a brilliant comedian to speak
so eloquently about a balanced life I
kind of argue against this point there's
such an obsession of creating this
healthy lifestyle no it's
psychologically speaking you know I'm a
fan of the idea that you sort of fly
high and you crash and die 27 mm hmm
there's also possible life and it's not
one we should judge because I think
there's moments of greatness I talk to
Olympic athletes where some of the
greatest moments are achieved in their
early 20s and
the rest of their life is it in the kind
of fog of almost of a depression because
they based on their physical prowess
physical prowess and they'll never say
that so they're watching the physical
prowess fade and they'll never achieve
the kind of height not just physical of
just emotion of the max number of
neurochemicals yes and he also put your
money on the wrong horse that's where I
would I would just go like oh yeah if
you're doing a job where you peak at 22
yeah the rest of your life is gonna be
hard
that idea is considering the notion that
you want to optimize some kind of but
we're all gonna die soon what now you
tell me I'm immortalized myself gonna be
fine see you're almost like how many
oscar-winning movies can I direct
by the time I'm 100 how many this and
that like but you know there's a night
you know it's all life is short speaking
I know but it can also come at different
you know life is short play hard fall in
love as much as you can run into walls I
would also go life is short
don't deplete yourself on things that
aren't sustainable and that you can't
keep yeah you know so I think everyone
gets dopamine from different places
everyone has meaning from different
places I look at the fleeting passionate
relationships I've had in the past and I
don't like I don't have pride in that I
think that you have to decide what you
know helps you sleep at night for me
it's pride and feeling like I behaved
with grace and integrity that's just me
personally everyone can go like yeah I
slept with all the hot chicks in Italy I
could and I you know did all the
whatever like whatever you value we're
allowed to value different here we're
talking about Brian Kelly yes Frank
Allen has lived his life to the fullest
to say the least but I think that it's
just for me personally I and this could
be like my workaholism or my achievement
ISM I if I don't have something to show
for something I feel like it's a waste
of time or some kind of loss
I'm a 12-step program and the third step
would say there's no such thing as waste
of time and everything happens exactly
as it should in whatever that's a way to
just sort of keep us sane so we don't
grieve too much and beat ourselves up
over past mistakes there's no such thing
as mistakes did it uh but um I think
passion is I think it's so
life-affirming and one of the few things
that maybe people like us makes us feel
awake and seen and we have just have
such a high threshold for adrenaline you
know I mean you are a fighter right yeah
okay so yeah so you have a very high
tolerance for adrenaline and I think
that Olympic athletes the amount of
adrenaline they get from performing it's
very hard to follow that it's like when
guys come back from the military and
they have depression it's like do you
miss bullets flying out you get kind of
because of that adrenaline which turned
into dopamine in the camaraderie I mean
there's people that speak much better
about this than I do but I just I'm
obsessed with neurology and I'm just
obsessed with sort of the lies we tell
ourselves in order to justify getting
neuro chemicals you've done actually
quite done a lot of thinking and talking
about neurology just kind of look at
human behavior through the lens of of
looking of how are actually chemically
our brain works so what first of all why
did you connect with that idea and what
have you how is your view of the world
changed by considering the the brain is
just a machine you know I know it
probably sounds really nihilistic but
for me it's very liberating to know a
lot about neuro chemicals because you
don't have to it's like the same thing
with like like critics like critical
reviews if you believe the good you have
to believe the bad kind of thing like
you know if you believe that your bad
choices were because of your moral
integrity or whatever you have to
believe your good ones I just think
there's something really liberating and
going like oh that was just adrenaline I
just said that thing because I was
adrenalized and I was scared and my
amygdala was activated and that's why I
said you're an [ __ ] and get out and
that's you know I think I just think
it's important to delineate what's
nature and what's nurture what is your
choice and what is just your brain
trying to keep you safe I think we
forget that even though we
security systems and homes and locks on
our doors that our brain for the most
part is just trying to keep us safe all
the time it's why we hold grudges that's
why we get angry it's why we get road
rage it's why we do a lot of things and
it's also when I started learning about
neurology I started having so much more
compassion for other people you know
someone yelled at me being like [ __ ] you
on the road I'd be like okay he's
producing adrenaline right now because
we're all going 65 miles an hour and our
brains aren't really designed for this
type of stress and he's scared he was
scared you know so that really helped me
to have more love for people and my
everyday life instead of being in
fight-or-flight mode but the I think
more interesting answer to your question
is that I've had migraines my whole life
like I've suffered with it really
intense migraines ocular migraines ones
where my arm would go numb and I just
started having to go to so many doctors
to learn about it and I started you know
learning that we don't really know that
much we know a lot but it's wild to go
into one of the best neurologists in the
world who's like yeah we don't know we
don't know we don't know and that
fascinated me that's one of the worst
pains you can probably have all that
stuff and we don't know the source we
don't know the source and there is
something really fascinating about when
your left arm starts going numb and you
start not being able to see out of the
left side of both your eyes and I
remember when the migraines get really
bad there it's like a mini-stroke almost
and you're able to see words on a page
but I can't read them they just look
like symbols to me so there's something
just really fascinating to me about your
brain just being able to stop
functioning and I so I just wanted to
learn about it study about it I did all
these weird alternative treatments they
got this piercing in here that actually
works I've tried everything and then
both my parents had strokes so when both
of my parents had strokes I became sort
of the person who had to decide what was
gonna happen with their recovery which
is just a wild thing to have to deal
with it you know 28 years old when it
happened and I started spending
basically all day every day and I see
used with neurologists learning about
what happened to my dad's brain and why
he can't move his left arm but he can
move his right leg but he can't see out
of that you know and then my mom had
another stroke
in a different part of the brain so I
started having to learn what parts of
the brain did what and so that I
wouldn't take the behavior so personally
and so that I would be able to manage my
expectations in terms of their recovery
so my mom because it affected a lot of
her frontal lobe changed a lot as a
person she was way more emotional she
was way more micromanage she was
forgetting certain things so it broke my
heart less when I was able to know oh
yeah will destroy hit this part of the
brain and that's the one that's
responsible for short-term memory and
that's responsible for long-term memory
set it up and then my brother just got
something called viral encephalitis
which is an infection inside the brain
and so Wow it was kind of wild that I
was able to go oh I know exactly what's
happening here and I know you know so um
so that's allows you to have some more
compassion for the struggles that people
have but does it take away some of the
magic for some of the from this some of
the more positive experiences in life
sometimes and I don't I don't I'm such a
control addict that you know I think our
biggest if someone like me my biggest
dream is to know why someone's doing
that's what stand-up is is just trying
to figure out why or that's what writing
is that's what acting is that's what
performing is it's trying to figure out
why someone would do something as an
actor you get a piece of you know
material and you go this person why
would he say that why would he pick up
that cup why would she walk over here
it's really why why would why so I think
neurology is if you're trying to figure
out human motives and why people do what
they do it'd be crazy not to understand
how neuro chemicals motivate us I also
have a lot of addiction in my family and
hardcore drug addiction and mental
illness and in order to cope with it you
really have to understand that
borderline personality disorder
schizophrenia and drug addiction so I
have a lot of people I love that suffer
from drug addiction and alcoholism and
the first thing they started teaching
you is it's not a choice these people's
dopamine receptors don't hold dopamine
the same ways yours do their frontal
lobe is underdeveloped like you know and
that really helped me to navigate
dealing loving people that were addicted
to substances I want to be careful with
this question but how much money do you
have
how much can I borrowed
okay know is how much control how much
despite the chemical imbalances or the
biological limitations that each of our
individual myself how much
mind-over-matter is there so through
things and I've known people with with
clinical depression and so it's it's
always a touchy subject to say how much
they can really help but very what can
you yeah what what can because you
you've you've talked about codependency
you talked about issues the your
struggle through and nevertheless you
choose to take a journey of healing and
so on so that's your choice that's your
actions so how much can you do to help
fight the limitations of the your
chemicals in your brain that's such an
interesting question I don't think I'm
at all qualified to answer but I'll say
what I do know and really quick just the
definition of codependency I think a lot
of people think of codependency is like
two people that can't stop hanging out
you know or like you know that's not
totally off but I think for the most
part my favorite definition of
codependency is the inability to
tolerate the discomfort of others you
grew up in an alcoholic home you grow up
around mental illness you grow up in
chaos you have a parent that's a
narcissist you basically are wired to
just people please worry about others be
perfect walk on eggshells shape-shift to
accommodate other people so codependency
is a very active wiring issue that you
know doesn't just affect your romantic
relationships it affects you being a
boss it affects you in the world online
you know you get one negative comment
and it throws you for two weeks you know
it also is linked to eating disorders
and other kinds of addictions so it's
it's it's a very big thing and I think a
lot of people sometimes to only think
that it's in a romantic relationship so
I always feel the need to say that and
also one of the reasons I love the idea
of robots so much because you don't have
to walk on eggshells around them you
don't have to worry they're gonna get
mad at you yet but you there's no
codependence are hypersensitive to the
needs and moods of others and it's very
exhausting it's depleting just a well
one
conversation about where we're gonna go
to dinner is like you want to go get
Chinese food
we just had Chinese food well wait are
you mad well no I didn't mean it's just
like that codependents live in this
everything means something and humans
can be very emotionally exhausting why
did you look at me that way what are you
thinking about what was that why'd you
check your phone it's just this it's a
hypersensitivity that can be incredibly
time-consuming which is why I love the
idea of robots just subbing in even I've
had a hard time running TV shows and
stuff because even asking someone to do
something I don't want to come off like
a [ __ ] I'm very concerned about what
other people think of me how I'm
perceived which is why I think robots
will be very beneficial for for
codependence by the way just a real
quick tangent that skill or flaw
whatever you want to call it is actually
really useful for if you ever do start
your own podcast for interviewing
because you're now kind of obsessed
about the mindset of others and it makes
you a good sort of listener and talker
with so I think what's your name from
NPR talked about Terry Gross talked
about having that so yeah oh I don't get
that at all
I mean you have to put yourself in the
mind of the person you're spoken to just
in terms of yeah I am starting a podcast
and the reason I haven't is because I'm
codependent I'm too worried it's not
gonna be perfect yeah so a big
codependent adage is perfectionism leads
to procrastination which leads to
paralysis so how do you sorry take a
million tangents how do you survive and
social media gives you exceptionally
active but by the way I took you on a
tangent and didn't answer your last
question about how much we can control I
want you to yeah we'll return it or
maybe night the answer is we can but you
know one of the things that I'm
fascinated by is you know the first
thing you learn when you go into 12-step
programs or addiction recovery I mean
this is you know genetics loads the gun
environment pulls the trigger and there
are certain parts of your genetics you
cannot control I come from a lot of
alcoholism I come from
you know a lot of mental illness there's
certain things I cannot control and a
lot of things that maybe we don't even
know yet what we can and can't because
of how little we actually know about the
brain but we also talk about the warrior
spirit and there are some people that
have that warrior spirit and we don't
necessarily know what that engine is
whether it's you get dopamine from
succeeding or achieving or martyring
yourself or or
that tension you get from growing so a
lot of people were like oh this person
can edify themselves and overcome but if
you're getting attention from improving
yourself you're going to keep wanting to
do that so that is something that helps
a lot of in terms of changing your brain
if you talk about changing your brain to
people and talk about what you're doing
to overcome set obstacles you're going
to get more attention from them which is
going to fire off your reward system and
then you're gonna keep doing it
see yeah so you can leverage that
momentum so this is why in any toe step
program you go into a room and you talk
about your progress because then
everyone claps for you and then you're
more motivated to keep going so that's
why we say you're only as sick as the
secrets you keep because if you keep
things secret you know there's no one
going and guiding you to go in a certain
direction it's based on right we're sort
of designed to get approval from the
tribe or from a group of people because
our brain you know translates it to
safety so in that case the tribe is a
positive one that helps you go this
direction so that's why it's so
important to go into a room and also say
hey I wanted to use drugs today and
people go hmm they go me too and then
feel less alone and you feel less like
you're you know have been castigated
from the pack or whatever and then you
say and I do haven't you get a chip when
you haven't drank for 30 days or 60 days
or whatever you get little rewards so
talking about a pack that's not at all
healthy or good but in fact is often
toxic social media so you're one of my
favorite people on Twitter and Instagram
to uh sort of just both the comedy and
the insight and just fun how do you
prevent social media from destroying
your mental health I haven't I haven't
it's the next big epidemic isn't it I
don't think I have I don't I don't think
it's moderation the answer what
maybe but you can do a lot of damage in
a moderate way I mean I guess again it
depends on your goals you know and and I
think for me the way that my addiction
to social media I'm happy to call it an
addiction I mean and I define as an
addiction because it stops being a
choice there are times I just reach over
and I'm like that was that was weird
Wow is weird I'll be driving sometimes
my bag oh my god my arm just went to my
home you know I can put it down I can't
take time away from it but when I do I
get antsy yeah I get restless irritable
and discontent I mean that's kind of the
definition isn't it so I think by no
means do I have a healthy relationship
with social media I'm sure there's a way
to but I think I'm especially a weirdo
in this space because it's easy to
conflate is this work is this I can
always say that it's for work right you
know but I mean you're don't you get the
same kind of thing as you get from when
a roomful of people laughs your jokes
I mean I see especially the way you do
Twitter it's an extension of your comedy
in a way so a big break from Twitter
though a really big break I took like
six months off or something for a while
because it was just like it seemed like
it was all kind of politics and it was
just a little bit
it wasn't giving me dopamine because
there was like this weird a lot of
feedback so I had to take a break from
it and then go back to except feel like
I didn't have a healthy relationship I
ever tried the I don't know if I believe
him but Joe Rogan seems to not read
comments have you and he's one of the
only people at the scale like a year
level who at least claims not to read so
like because you and him swim in this
space of tense ideas yeah they get get
get the toxic folks growled up I think
rogue I don't I don't know I don't mmm I
think he probably looks at YouTube like
the likes and that you know I think if
something's if he doesn't know I don't
know I'm sure he would tell the truth
you know I'm sure he's got people that
look at them and he's like disgusted
great or I don't you know like I'm sure
he gets it you know I I can't picture
him like in the weeds on know for sure I
mean I
nameste she's saying that just it's it's
uh it's a to feedback yeah we're just a
feedback I mean you know look like I
think that our brain is designed to get
intel on how we're perceived so that we
know where we stand right that's our
whole deal right as humans we want to
know where we stand we walk into a room
and we go who's the most powerful person
in here I gotta talk to him and get in
their good graces it's just were
designed to rank ourselves right and
constantly know our rank and social
media because of you can't figure out
your rank with 500 million people you
get small you know cert brain is like
what's my rank what's my and especially
for following people I think the the big
the the interesting thing I think I may
be be able to able to say about this
besides my speech impediment is that I
did start muting people that ranked
wildly higher than me because it is just
stressful on the brain to constantly
look at people that are incredibly
successful so you keep feeling bad about
yourself you know I think that that is
like cutting to a certain extent just
like look at me looking at all these
people that have so much more money than
me and so much more success than me it's
making me feel like a failure even
though I don't think I'm a failure but
it's easy to frame it so that I can feel
that but yeah that's really interesting
especially if they're close to like if
there are other comedians like that or
whatever that's that's it's really
disappointing to me I do the same thing
as well so other successful people
they're really close to what I do it I
don't know I I wish I could just admire
ya and for it not to be a distraction
but that's why you are where you are cuz
you don't just didn't Meyer you're
competitive and you want to win so it's
also the same thing that bums you out
when you look at this is the same reason
you are where you are so that's why I
think it's so important to learn about
neurology and addiction because you're
able to go like oh this same instinct so
I'm very sensitive and I and I sometimes
don't like that about myself that I'm
like well that's the reason I'm able to
write good stand-up and that's the
reason and that's reason I'm able to be
sensitive to feedback and go that joke
should have been better I can make that
better so it's a kind of thing where
it's like you have to be really
sensitive in your work in the second you
leave you've got to be able to turn it
off it's about developing the muscle
being able to know when to let it be a
superpower
when it's gonna hold you back and be an
obstacle so I try to not be in that
black and white of like you know being
competitive is bad or being jealous of
someone just to go like oh there's that
thing that makes me really successful in
a lot of other ways but right now it's
making me feel that well I'm kind of
looking to you because your ear
basically a celebrity the famous sort of
world-class comedian and so I feel like
you're the right person to be one of the
key people to define what's the healthy
path forward with social media so I
because we're all trying to figure it
out now and it's a I'm curious to see
where it involves and I think you're at
the center of that so likely you know
there's you know trying to leave Twitter
and then come back how can I do this in
a healthy way you mean you have to keep
trying exploring it because it's being I
have a couple answers I think you know I
hire a company to do some of my social
media for me you know so it's also being
able to go okay I make a certain amount
of money by doing this but now let me be
a good businessperson and say I'm gonna
pay you this amount to run this for me
so I'm not 24/7 in the weeds hash
tagging and responding and just it's a
lot to take on it's a lot of energy to
take on but at the same time part of
what I think makes me successful in
social media if I am is that people know
I'm actually doing it and then I am an
engaging and I'm responding and
developing a personal relationship with
complete strangers so I think you know
figuring out that balance and really
approaching it as a business you know
that's what I try to do it's not dating
it's not you know I try to just be
really objective about okay here's
what's working here's what's not working
and in terms of taking the break from
Twitter this is a really savage take but
because I don't talk about my politics
publicly being on Twitter right after
the last election was not gonna be
beneficial because there was gonna be
had to take a side you had to be
political in order to get any kind of
retweets or likes and I just wasn't
interested in doing that because you
were gonna lose as many people as you
were gonna gain and it was gonna all
complain in the wash so I was just like
the best thing I can do for me
business-wise is to just abstain you
know and you know the robot I joke about
her replacing
but she does do half of my social media
you know yeah because it's I don't want
people to get sick of me I don't want to
be redundant there are times when I
don't have the time or the energy to
make a funny video but I know she's
gonna be compelling and interesting and
that's something that you can't see
every day you know of course the the the
humor comes from Europe I mean the
cleverness the wit the humor comes from
you when you film the robot that's kind
of the trick of it I mean the the robot
is not quite there to making to do
anything funny
the absurdity is revealed through the
filmmaker in that case where whoever is
interacting not through the the actual
robot you know being who she is let me
sort of love okay how do what is it they
have what is it
well first an engineering question I
know I know you're you're not an
engineer but how difficult do you think
is it to build an AI system that you can
have a deep fulfilling monogamous
relationship with sort of replace the
human human relationships that we value
I think anyone can fall in love with
anything you know like how often have
you looked back in someone like I ran
into someone the other day that I was in
love with then I was like hey it was
like there was nothing there no there
was nothing there like do you know like
where you're able to go like oh that was
weird
oh honey you know I were able to me as
from a distant past or something
yeah when you're able to go like I can't
believe we had an incredible connection
and now it's just I do think that people
will be in love with robots
probably even more deeply with humans
because it's like when people mourn
their animals when their animals die
they're always it's sometimes harder
than mourning a human because you can't
go well he was kind of an [ __ ] but
like he didn't pick me up from school
you know it's like you're able to get
out of your grief a little bit you're
able to kind of be oh he was kind of
judgmental or she was cut you know with
a robot it's there's something so pure
about an innocence and fish and
childlike about it
that I think it probably will be much
more conducive to a narcissistic love
for sure at that but it's not like well
he cheated us she can't cheat she can't
leave you she can't you know well a bear
claw leaves your life and maybe a new
version or somebody else will enter
there will you miss bear claw for guys
that have these sex robots they're
building a nursing home for the bodies
well that are now rusting because they
don't want to part with the bodies
because they have such an intense
emotional connection to it I mean it's
kind of like a car club a little bit you
know like it's it you know but I'm not
saying this is right I'm not saying it's
cool it's weird it's creepy but we do
anthropomorphize things with faces and
we do develop emotional connections to
things
I mean we're there certain have you ever
tried to like throw it I can't even
throw away my teddy bear from when I was
a kid it's a piece of trash and it's
upstairs like it's like why can't I
throw that away it's bizarre you know
and there's something kind of beautiful
about that there's something it gives me
hope in in humans because I see humans
do such horrific things all the time and
maybe I'm too I see too much of it
frankly but there's something kind of
beautiful about the way we're able to
have emotional connections to objects
which you know a lot of I mean it's kind
of specifically I think Western right
that we don't see objects as having
Souls like that's kind of specifically
us but um I don't think it's so much
that we're objectifying humans with
these sex robots were kind of humanizing
objects right so there's something kind
of fascinating in our ability to do that
because a lot of us don't humanize
humans so it's just a weird little place
to play in and I think a lot of people I
mean a lot of people will be marrying
these things is my guess so
you've asked the question let me ask it
of you so what is love you have a bit of
a brilliant definition of love
as being willing to die for someone we
who you yourself want to kill so that's
that's kind of fun first of all that's
brilliant that's a really good
definition I think you'll stick with me
for a long time is this how little of a
romantic I am a plane went by when you
said that and my brain is like you're
gonna need to rerecord that and I want
you to get into post and then not be
able to use and I'm a romantic as a mom
I actually I cannot be conscious of the
fact that I heard the plane and it made
me feel like how amazing it is that we
live in a world planes and I just why
haven't we [ __ ] evolved past planes
and why can't they make them quieter
yeah yeah this my definition of love
what what yeah what's your producing
dopamine consistent output of oxytocin
with the same person
dopamine is a positive thing what about
the negative what about the fear and the
insecurity the longing anger all that
kind of stuff I think that's part of
love you know I think you don't I think
that love brings out the best in you but
it also if you don't get angry upset
it's you know I don't know I think that
that's that's part of it I think we have
this idea that love has to be like
really you know placid or something
I only saw stormy relationships growing
up so I don't I don't have a judgment on
how a relationship should look but I do
think that this idea that love has to be
eternal is is really destructive is
really destructive and self-defeating
and a big source of stress for people I
mean I'm still figuring out love I think
we all kind of are but I do kind of
stand by that definition and I think
that uh I think for me love is like just
being able to be authentic with somebody
it's very simple I know but I think for
me it's about not feeling pressure to
have to perform or impress somebody just
feeling truly like accepted
unconditionally by someone although I do
believe love should be conditional that
might be a hot take I think everything
should be conditional I think if
someone's behavior I don't think love
should just be like
I'm in love with you now behave however
you want forever this is unconditional I
think love is a daily action it's not
something you just like get ten you're
on and then get to behave however you
want because we said I love you 10 years
ago it's a daily it's a verb well
there's some things there you see if you
make it if you explicitly make it clear
that it's conditional it takes away some
of the magic of it so there's some
stories we tell ourselves that we don't
want to make explicit about love I don't
know maybe that's the wrong way to think
of it maybe you want to be explicit in
relationships so something love is a
business decision like I do in a good
way yeah I think that love is not just
when you're across from somebody it's
when I go to work can I focus do I am I
worried about you am I stressed out
about you am I you're not responding to
me you're not reliable like I think that
being in a relationship the kind of love
that I would want is the kind of
relationship where when we're not
together it's not draining me causing me
stress making me worry you know and
sometimes passion that word
you know we'd get murky about it but I
think it's also like I can be the best
version of myself when the person's not
around and I don't have to feel
abandoned or scared or any of these kind
of other things so it's like love you
know for me I think is I think it's a
flow Barre quote and I'm gonna butcher
it but I think it's like be you know
boring in your personal life so you
could be violent and take risks in your
professional life is that it I got it
wrong something like that but I do think
that it's being able to align values in
a way to where you can also thrive
outside of the relationship some of the
most successful people I know are sort
of happily married and have kids and so
on it's it's always funny boring boring
is okay foreign is serenity and it's
funny how that those elements actually
make you much more productive I don't
understand the I don't think
relationships should drain you and take
away energy that you could be using to
create things that generate pride okay
did you say your relationship of love
yet have you said you're really your
definition of love my definition of love
no I did not say it we're out of time
do what when you have when you have a
podcast maybe you can invite me on alone
oh no I already did you're doing it
we've already talked about this and
because I also have codependency I have
to say yes yeah actually what the I
wondered whether when I I asked if we
could talk today after sort of doing
more research and reading some of your
book I start to wonder did she just feel
pressured to say yes no I actually
because I am putting on but I've been
recovered for codependents so I actually
do I don't do anything I don't want to
do you really you got anywhere saying no
but good November I moved it from 1 to 2
yeah just yeah I don't do anything I
don't want to do yeah you're ahead of me
in that okay so do you think about your
mortality yes it is a big part of how I
was able to sort of like kickstart my
codependence recovery my dad passed a
couple years ago and when you have
someone close to you in your life died
everything gets real clear in terms of
how were a speck of dust who's only here
for a certain amount of time what do you
think is the meaning of it all like what
the speck of dust
what what's maybe in your own life
what's the goal the purpose of your
existence is there one well you you're
exceptionally ambitious you've created
some incredible things in different
disciplines we're all just managing our
terror because we know we're gonna die
so we create and build all these things
and rituals and religions and you know
robots and whatever we need to do to
just distract ourselves from imminent
rotting rotting yeah we're all dying and
you know III you know I got very into
terror management theory when my dad
died and and it resonated it helped me
and everyone's got their own religion or
sense of purpose or thing that distracts
them from the horrors of
being what's terror management theory
terror management is basically the idea
that since we're the only animal that
knows they're gonna die we have to
basically distract ourselves with awards
and achievements and games and sperm
whatever just in order to distract
ourselves from the terror we would feel
if we really processed the fact that we
could not only we are gonna die but also
could die at any minute because we're
only superficially at the top of the
food chain and you know we technically
were the top of the food chain if we
have houses and guns and stuff machines
but if me and a lion are in the woods
together I'm it's most things could kill
us I mean a bee can kill some people
like something this big can kill a lot
of humans like you know so it's
basically just to manage the terror that
we all would feel if we were able to
really be awake because we're mostly
zombies right new job school religion
zoo so go to sleep drink through the
football the relationship don't mean
love but you know we're kind of just
like trudging along like zombies for the
most part and then I think that fear of
death as some motivation yes well I
think I speak for a lot of people in
saying that I can't wait to see what
your terror creates in the in the next
few years I'm a huge fan wouldn't you
thank you so much for talking to
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Whitney Cummings and
thank you to our presenting sponsor cash
app download it and use code let's
podcast you'll get ten dollars and ten
dollars will go to first stem education
nonprofit that inspires hundreds of
thousands of young minds to learn and to
dream of engineering our future if you
enjoy this podcast subscribe on youtube
give it five stars an apple podcast
supported on patreon or connect with me
on Twitter thank you for listening and
hope to see you next time
you